what's more likely time for week 15
brown's giants
in a big spot flexed into prime time hey
cowboys get the flex out of here is
basically what the nfl
said what's more likely miles garrett
has zero sacks or daniel jones
has zero turn i made you laugh while you
were drinking
what's more likely miles garrett has
zero sacks or daniel jones has zero
turnovers now
jones has three straight games without a
turnover
before three fumbles one lost against
the cardinals and garrett has
a sack in eight of his 11 games this
season so what's more likely i
i like that uh they get you almost made
me choke on my car
get the flex out of here cowboys all
right i could
i could use that in my repertoire uh i
think
there's there's really i mean
sacks and turnovers garrett daniel jones
i i they're they easily could both
happen
but the one i'll say like miles garrett
is gonna get a sack in this football
game that is a guarantee with that
giants offensive line
the way they played last week and of
course he's the best pass rusher in
football off the edge not named you know
aaron donald who's not on the edge most
of the times
so i'll go with daniel jones as zero
turnovers
even though i don't feel real
comfortable about that because of the
stats you
talked about already and all that but
one thing i know is that miles garrett's
gonna get a sack
on sunday night football you know it
would be easy for me to say i think
daniel jones is going to get zero
turnovers because there's a chance he's
not going to play
joe judge said yesterday that he hasn't
decided whether it's going to be daniel
jones or colt mccoy jones has an ankle
injury
on top of the hamstring and judge said
that jones will play if he can protect
himself like he would in a normal game
but he hasn't made a decision yet
as to whether it will be jones or the
former browns quarterback colt mccoy
under center chiefs 12-1 at the 10-3
saints what's more likely
patrick mahomes throws one interception
or taysom hill throws
two or more touchdown passes and taysom
hill has had two straight games
with two passing touchdowns mahomes as
we know had three interceptions for the
second time in his career
on sunday against the dolphins what's
more likely yeah there's another good
one by pete here i mean it really is
because it
you know it's very realistic to think
that both of these could happen
especially when you take into account
like the saints we know
taysom hill they're going to run the
ball the chiefs are a team
mike that they're kind of a what i would
call an all or nothing team
they bring the house or they drop it
drop the house into coverage
it's one of the other and that could
lead to
some wide open people you know in the
past game this week when you're worried
about
hey let's crowd the line of scrimmage
and let's smother taysom hill and alvin
kamara in the run game
and then all of a sudden emmanuel
sanders or michael thomas are
you know one on one flying down the
middle of the field so very realistic
there
but i think if i'm going to pick one of
the other i'm going to say mahomes
throws one interception
all right i'll take that i think the
saints defense is going to do some
creative things they're going to bounce
back from that crappy effort they had
last week
i would think that d-line you know one
thing and i talked about this on my
podcast yesterday that we just overlook
a little bit
with patrick mahomes how well
he moves he is so good in the pocket i
think sometimes we give
their offense a line a little bit of a
free pass and go
well they're they're pretty good at pass
protecting you know but i go back and
watch that dolphins game last week and i
go
actually the protection wasn't that good
he just he moves and makes so many plays
so often that we don't even make a big
deal about it anymore we really don't
that's that's how amazing this damn guy
is
uh but i guess i could see my homes
throwing the one interception more than
the two plus td passes for taysom hill
what do you think
i got a different analysis here i think
that it will be imperative for the
saints to score points if they're gonna
have any chance of winning this game so
hill had better throw at least two
touchdown passes or they're not going to
have a chance because
you're not going to outscore the chiefs
if taysom hill isn't throwing the ball
down the field hopefully this will be a
shootout on par with what we saw on
monday night but
they're done i'd be stunned if they win
the game
without hill throwing at least two
touchdown passes i'd be stunned if they
stay within 10 points of the chiefs if
hill doesn't throw at least two
touchdown passes so i think that's going
to be a key part of the overall
offensive game plan
on sunday for the saints all right next
up bears six and seven
vikings six and seven elimination game
not that the winner is going to make it
to the playoffs either what's more
likely david montgomery gets 75 or more
rushing yards
for the bears or dalvin cook gets 100
plus for the vikings chris
and i say that because montgomery
actually
has better numbers over the last three
weeks
yeah i know and i mean of course the
bears defense we know it's pretty legit
montgomery and the bears offense have
kind of found their mojo here
as of late we've talked about it a few
times the last two offensive
you know performances for the bears
against the lions and the houston texans
i know it's not great defenses but the
offense has looked
different that's for sure i think if i'm
i'm with this one 75 plus yards for
david montgomery against the vikings
defense
i like the chances of that more than i
do dalvin cook
getting over a hundred i think he could
flirt with it again
you know against this bears team but i
don't think he quite gets there this
week
i'm gonna go with uh montgomery the 75
plus
yeah i agree too and frankly i think
mitchell trubisky matches up much better
with the vikings than nick foles despite
what foles did to the vikings in the nfc
championship
game three years ago the vikings have
been bedeviled by trubisky
throughout his career and and uh i got a
feeling you know i joked around earlier
this week well i know what's gonna
happen the vikings will beat the bears
they'll beat the saints and then they'll
lose to the lions and not make it to the
playoffs let's just go ahead and put the
fork in them now i think they're going
to lose this i don't want to tip my
picks coming up
hey uh later today is our podcast where
we pick all the games i i don't think
the vikings are going to win this game
and i think dalvin cook's going to get
shut down and i think it's going to be a
long day
at home for the vikings it's going to be
you know we've seen them play these home
games where
there's this what the hell is going on
vibe and they finally wake up
i just think against a team like the
bears are not going to be able to wake
up against the panthers against the
jaguars they were able to wake up it's
not going to work against the bears
all right patriots dolphins what's more
likely cam newton throws a touchdown
pass
or tuatango vailoa throws an
interception
newton has five touchdown passes this
year as peter king pointed out yesterday
in 2015 he had five touchdown passes in
three different games he's got five
total this year
tua has one interception and six starts
what's more likely
cam newton td pass or tua interception
well i i can't ever say that i'm
expecting a cam newton td pass
not you know not with that offense the
way they play all of that
to a i know it was his first
interception last week
you know he's dodged the bullet a little
bit you know in his first few starts or
probably could have had you know a few
others
i'm gonna go with that you know with the
patriots a little extra time
they're secondary i think the
predictability a little bit
within the dolphins offense right now
because of
hey he's a young quarterback and they're
not trying to do too much
that'll play into the hands of you know
the belichick's being able to do some
creative things and confuse him on the
back end
just at least a few times and mike what
is the what's the status devante parker
i know he was a little banged up too
that's another
huge aspect of that football game and
when we know those patriots they're
going to play man-to-man if he doesn't
have a guy like devonte out there
oh that could be tough sledding for that
dolphins offense
and there's that there's that statistic
about bill belichick's success the
first pass through against young
quarterbacks and and i don't have it in
front of me
but he with with extra time to get ready
a little upset after getting manhandled
by
the rams on thursday night and there's
audio of belichick saying to sean
mcveigh
after the game you guys killed us
tonight i i think
two is gonna have his hands full plus
enough film right enough games out there
of two are playing that bill belichick
will come up with something i think it's
more likely we see an interception
from tua than uh a a touchdown pass from
cam
although i think there's a chance we're
going to see both because i i think that
the offense will be good enough for new
england and the defense will be better
than good enough again i don't want to
tip too many of my picks
but this feels like a trap isn't it odd
to think
dolphins playing the patriots is a trap
for miami it's kind of feeling like a
little bit of a trap to me
all right seahawks at washington what's
more likely
washington gets more than five sacks of
russell wilson or fewer
than two washington is tied for fourth
this year with 40 sacks chris
and the seahawks have 41 sacks allowed
of russell wilson that's tied for third
most in the league i hear your dog
barking
yes he is barking i have a feeling
somebody might be shoveling snow out
there and i need to tell him to shut
it's okay bentley
be quiet all right so here we go you do
have a bentley after all
i do exactly right it's 20 20 it's the
pandemic
we're in the snowstorm and we're doing
the show from home okay that's just the
way
that pete says tell that dog to shut the
hell up
right yeah seriously uh all right i mean
this is on the low key a very
interesting football
game you know you mentioned it that
washington defense it's pretty damn
special
you know they're they've got they've
crossed over into the
the line or conversation of like hey
we're so damn good we can almost win the
game by
ourselves like offense as long as you
don't screw it up
we'll give you great field position
we'll cause a few turnovers and hey we
might score ourselves too
i mean they've gotten to that to where
you have to be so
aware with washington to almost go
hey offense let's not mess the game up
their offense is not very good
i still look at it last week with the
49ers if they were willing to play a
13-10 game or six
and just play really conservative
there's no way they're gonna lose
they're not
you know two touchdowns by washington's
defense that won the game for them
i'm gonna say that it's fewer than two
if you make me choose i mean i know
likely it's gonna be in the middle of
there but
five sacks or fewer than two i'm gonna
go fewer than two because i think
russell wilson is gonna be very aware
about
negative plays against this team and
that they're offensively challenged and
he'll
he'll know that the broad picture look
of what this
what needs to be done in this game yeah
i agree with you this is definitely not
a let ross cook game this is a get back
to old-school seahawks and just wear
them
kind of not not step into the bear trap
of of letting that great front seven
tee off on russell wilson and chase him
around because as great as he is
he's been caught more than uh we would
have expected this year with those 41.
he's not as fast as he used to be that
that's there's no doubt about that
i mean i think you see it a little at
least i do it's still fast
i thought it was just i thought it was
just kyler murray when you see the two
of them in the same game
i thought that that kyler murray's speed
made russell wilson
look a little bit less explosive but you
may be onto something
you know he's he's too young to be
losing any of it but i don't
i don't get it because that it's not
what it used to be i agree with you
yeah i think it's just hey it is age
you're going to look at this
at this age where he's at right now you
know what is what is russell wilson
right now 30 32
30 32 32 you might lose a little
something there
just a little bit of explosiveness you
know the other thing too
is you know you get older you start to
get bigger and thicker right you know
that's that's the case with men for a
lot of the times and i think he's a
naturally thick
muscular guy too to where he's probably
going to balance that out but
still elusive as hell we know that but
you know
i'm with you i think at one point i just
thought well there's so many damn fast
quarterbacks in football right now
that's why he doesn't look as fast but
the more i've watched i go no
you know last year the year before i've
seen a few plays where i go he gets away
from this guy
and he's not getting away from it and
just getting like those shoestring
tackles this year so yeah something to
watch out for
you are right though there is a point
where the metabolism begins to betray
you and you have to actually be
careful about what you eat and how often
you exercise
lest uh your your clothes be shrunk by
the washing machine
all right last one eagles four eight and
one at the seven and six cardinals
what's more likely jalen hurts rushes
for 50 or more yards
or kyler murray rushes for 50 or more
yards kyler has
seven games of 50 plus this year
but none in the last four
yeah i think between him being banged up
a little bit
i think they're a little reluctant to
run him i think they're quietly
you know trying to keep his injury and
him being banged up maybe under the
radar
and then the eagles run defense is real
you know and as we always talk about
with the cardinals you know it's
people have figured out that that pass
offense so therefore
they've been able to now okay i got that
figured out
now how do we stop him running and doing
that type of stuff so i'm gonna go with
jalen hurts rushes for 50 plus
i don't that's going to be tough too
because this arizona defense they got
some speed
up front with guys as far as hassan
riddick and simmons the top 10 pick and
jordan hicks and
guys that can run down the quarterback
but i still think since it's new
and you don't know exactly how they're
going to attack you and do do that yet
i'm going to go with jalen hurts here
what do you think i think we're going to
see an overcorrection by the arizona
defense
uh in light of what we saw hertz do
against the saints so i'm going to go
with kyle
he's four weeks plus removed from that
shoulder injury he should be
healing up now and and we're i think
we're going to see
early season kyler as they get closer
and closer to grabbing the brass ring of
a playoff berth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports